الخبر العاج الذي يظهر على شاشاتنا الان
بحسب مراسل الجزيره وصول وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي غفير للمشاركه في مسيره
الاعلام بالقدس سنتحول مره اخرى الى باب
العمود ونجوان السمري بن غفير طبعا يشارك
في مثل هذه المسيرات بشكل
معتاد لكن
ما المختلف هذه المره
وهو في منصب وزير في هذه الحكومه التي
توصف بالاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل بني
كبير يشارك في هذه
المسيره وكان قد هدد ايضا والمحا في
الايام الاخيره الماضيه انه قد يشارك ايضا
في اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى المباركه
معتاده على فعله في السابق لكنه لم يقتحم
هذا اليوم المسجد الاقصى الاقصى كما فعل
تماما بعد تشكيل هذه الحكومه في بدايه هذا
العام الجاري وقام باقتحام المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وكانت خطوه اثاره غضب وردود فعل
واسعه من قبل الجانب الفلسطيني ومن قبل
عده دول عربيه ايضا لكن هذه المره يشارك
بني كبير في هذه المسيره التي لطالما
اشارك فيها في السابق ايضا قبل حتى ان
يكون عضوه كنيست ولكن عندما اصبح عضو
كنيست والان وهو الشرطه وزير الامن
الداخلي في اسرائيل هو عمليا وزير الشرطه
ولكنه يشارك في هذه
المسيره ضمن توجهاته بطبيعه الحال بانه
يدعم هذه المسيره يدعم التوجه الاستيطاني
المتطرف
وكل مثل هذه النشاطات التي ينظمها
المتطرفون الاسرائيليون لكن ليس فقط بين
كبير هناك العديد من اعضاء الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي ايضا في حزب الليكود الذي
يتزعمه رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
يشاركون في هذه المسيره راينا منهم الكثير
وايضا رئيس لجنه الخارجيه والامن في
الكنيست رايناه ايضا يشارك في هذه المسيره
ادلشتاين وهو ايضا من حزب الليكود
وبالتالي ما كنت اشير اليه سابقا زينه
العابدين انه لا يمكن ان ان نحصر هذه
المسيره وهذه النشاطات وهذه
الانتهاكات مدينه القدس على فئات معينه في
داخل اسرائيل تقتصر على المستوطنين
والمتطرفين اليهود هي تمثل الحكومات
الاسرائيليه السياسات الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتتاليه كم بالحريه عندما
تكون هذه الحكومه هي الحكومه الاكثر تطرفا
كما توصف حتى اسرائيليا في تاريخ اسرائيل
وبها مثل التيارات الصهيونيه الدينيه
المتطرفه جزء من الائتلاف الحاكم هم
يشكلون هذه الحكومه هم وزراء في هذه
الحكومه يشاركون في اقتحامات الاقصى
يشاركون في هذه المسيره يدلون بتصريحات في
قمه العنصريه ضد الفلسطينيين لا ننسى
عندما دعا الى محو قريه حواره الفلسطينيه
ومثله كثر قبل فتره وجيزه فقط قبل ان يبدا
التصعيد الاخير على غزه قالت وزيره في هذه
الحكومه
تدعى قالت بانها كانت تتمنى لو تستيقظ بعد
ان تم اطلاق صواريخ من قبل فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه
والمستوطنات غلاف غزه في اعقاب استشهاد
الاسير خضر عدنان قالت في مقابله اذاعيه
انها كانت تتمنى ان تستيقظ على مباني
مهدمه ومزيد من القتلى في داخل غزه هذا هو
توجه هذه الحكومه ربما يقال بانها الحكومه
الاكثر تطرفا ولكنها ايضا اكثر صريحه من
حكومات اسرائيليه سابقه بمعنى انه لا يوجد
اي رادع لهؤلاء الوزراء او لهؤلاء لاعضاء
الكنيست المتطرفين التفوهم بمثل هذه
التصريحات او المشاركه في مثل هذه الانشطه
بشكل علني وبالتالي بن جزير يشارك في هذه
المسيره وهو على راس مثل هذه النشاطات
وهذه فعاليات وكانت له تصريحات يوم امس
بان هذه المسيره سيتم تنظيمها ولن تخضع
اسرائيل كما قال او تذعن لاي من التهديدات
من قبل منظمات وصفها بالارهابيه وبالتالي
الوزير المسؤول عنه الشرطه في اسرائيل هو
جزء من هذه المسيره وكذلك كان هناك عده
اعضاء كنيست ووزير اخر ايضا في حزم بني
جفير شارك صباح هذا اليوم في اقتحامات
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وبالتالي مثل هذه
الاجراءات مثل مشاركه لوزراء او لاعضاء
كنيست بطبيعه الحال تحتاج الى موافقه من
رئيس الحكومه تحتاج الى موافقه من اجهزه
الامن الاسرائيليه لتامين مشاركتهم ايضا
في هذه المسيره وهم بطبيعه الحال يشجعون
المستوطنين والمتطرفين اليهود على مثل
هذه الانتهاكات لاسيما وانهم بطبيعه الحال
يشكلون جزء من هذه الانتهاكات عندما يتم
حذف المستوطنين على تكثيف اعداد المقتحمين
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك ويشارك في مثل هذه
الاقتحمات جزء من الائتلاف الحاكم من
الاحزاب الحاكمه من هذه الحكومه هذا عمليا
ضوء اخضر للاستمرار في هذه الانتهاكات
وهذه الهتافات التي نسمعها حاليا الموت
للعرب الموت للعرب هذه لاتافات التي تتكرر
في كل مناسبه للمستوطنين